to the end of the first quarter with the
rhinos in the red zone for the first
time
got to say bill i like watching these
rhinos ransom takes the snap drops back
with good protection and that's a
completed pass to a very wide open
hingle mccrinkleberry the rookie out of
penn state
nice grab i'm a kringleberry you think
he's happy oh boy he is loving it down
there
oh we got something of a shooting
gallery oh yeah look at that boy that is
something and
oh oh wait we got a flag though you got
that for excessive celebration yeah
well see and i'm not sure about that
called i don't know bill that was three
pumps and the rule book says you cannot
have more than two
oh my gosh but look at the kid he's
pleading his case with draft pleading
his case
yeah clearly three pops coast johnson
definitely not happy about this call
five minutes into the fourth quarter
third and ten the rhinos again
threatening to score can the cougars
hold them big play coming here bill
ransom takes the snap drops back he
floats one into the end zone and
mcringleberry pulls it down oh he's got
it
oh my gosh for his second touchdown of
the day for this rookie he has got to be
feeling great about himself nice
i'll tell you man he's oh oh see now
there's two pumps
yeah he's really testing the boundaries
and he's clearly gotten the refs
attention here
a third pump will draw a flag no matter
what see oh he just did it again
what did now what is that the second
time now you have to flag him on it yeah
he had to you know bill it's just
frustrating seeing young players without
the ability to restrain themselves oh it
really is
it's hard i mean the ref's gonna get you
every time yeah
yeah absolutely uh see now the ref
agrees that's three pumps right there
[Applause]
and the quarterback ransom under center
last five minutes of the game
rhinos are marching here again hard to
stop this team from scoring bill they
have so many weapons
ransom takes the snap and it's a shovel
past the mccringleberry ooh he's at the
10.
he's at the five and touchdown rhino oh
my
great block by hardunka chut and that's
gonna be tough for the cougars to come
back from boy what a career day from
hingle mccrinkleberry the rookie out of
penn state
oh he was just amazingly fired up here
today jeff you got to love the way this
guy plays and he
oh oh see now there's one pump oh
well i cannot believe this kid you got
to put your team
first in situations like this and the
kringleberry's just not doing it no
there's two
jeff now if he pumps a third time he
will draw his third penalty for today
everybody here waiting with betty breath
amazing i mean come on in professional
football it's really changed yeah that's
what it is
you can argue all you want but flag well
it's been thrown that's right if it's
three pumps the ref's not gonna take it
away not
duration and intensity doesn't make any
difference jeff let's have a look at the
replay here to see if indeed he did do
the three pumps
all right no question there is the first
one yeah right
agreed right and then coming up is the
second one
okay yes very clear it's the third we'll
see it it's coming out
here oh yeah you're right there's
absolutely three pumps there
oh uh apologies to all those watching
with young children uh clearly
unintentional
you